[Music]
in rodent racer news submitted by our
patreon a course like a throw thora
thank you something gore slagathor
you've been an amazing future on by the
way we saw thank you what do you do I'll
tell you later it's been slugging it
thorat scientists have trained rats to
drive tiny cars to collect food they
need cars don't they go fast already no
that's our pretty fast
yeah there's a car going faster than
they already go yeah cuz if it's slower
than how they already goes kind of
useless is just getting queued on us
they did train rats play basketball
didn't why rats can do a lot of [ __ ]
yeah like what anything named Ethan do
apparently they can play that to the
moon yes they've bonded no but did they
operate the actual rocket they operated
the rocket they were in when they're in
space hey no karahi Splinter alright so
rats have now mastered the art of
driving a tiny car and so that suggests
division right still crashing though so
this is suggesting that their brains are
more flexible than we had thought
and so they are saying we're deep inside
though we thought we thought that they
were just what we thought so stupid huh
now that there is smart up to the point
that we thought so is it they're smart
do they not ok so then they say what we
do know is that rodents can learn to
recognize objects press bars and find
their way around mazes and so they're
saying that these tests often are used
to study how brain conditions affect
cognitive function but they only capture
a narrow window of animal cognition do
they teach them how to use the horn
because they're typing dude have you
haven't seen the one where the girls she
trains her rats and she was at you and
then the rat runs and he gets a little
tushy
the man pictures of this or video more
video I whoa here we go
why would you ask for pictures this is
at the University of Richmond wives so
cute yeah me too oh it's good job I
wanted to see like an old Ford T model
the thing is like they have to read that
or they're able to control like how to
move like now and then so they're being
rewarded by tiny little fruit loop
pieces oh no they would move the pieces
like dependent like they would make the
distance rates of obesity too much and
then also like they would change the
positions like if they face them this
way but the fruit loops is over there
like they're able to like turn and like
take it that's [ __ ] tight nesic yeah I
do it for fruit loops all the colors
over here and look at these driving that
[ __ ] I guess I was just expecting
something different I was expecting him
in a little truck or something like a
Tom and Jerry or situation rap and the
groups called the rat pack yeah the rat
pack got a little rat hat and it's like
beat beat little headlights Edie pbbt
all right like if they are hamsters like
those hamster commercials where they're
huge kiss or I didn't like that it's
better though it's better than better
than this that's for sure I like that
there's a scientist there that sees this
and he's like yes and then you're like
so what do we take away from this he's
like no I think the scientists are more
like interested what what if this was a
big commercial for fruit loops
no so they're saying that the ability of
rats to drive these cars demonstrates
the neuroplasticity of their brains
awesome first to their ability to
respond flexibly flexibly
sex flexibly does a basketball already
show us how flexible the [ __ ]
neuroplasticity is - apparently not
enough I'm not a scientist people ask
you Gor why do we need to study dresses
deeply yeah that's true pan Rath drive
vehicle take over answer being yes okay
another part that I first mentioned so
they also they were they were observing
like their brain waves and stuff
measuring hormones and they were
measuring the hormone road rage - he's
[ __ ] pissed actually they found the
opposite that way right yeah when rats
were driving they were really like they
had a lot of reduced stress they haven't
been on the 405
that's why empty cage no [ __ ] problem
yeah because you didn't have to walk
that's like driving an airport hangar
sick that is relaxing yeah so they're
saying that this became less stressed
after they mastered difficult tests like
damn very buried food so they're saying
that driving this car was reducing was
it driving the car or gaining the fruit
loop right no they were able to reward
themselves by a less stressful way of
getting there than to like go through me
know put a fruit loop at the very end of
the maze then put 20 rats and carbs in
there and have them all try to get there
at the same that is actually so the
follow-up experiments are to understand
how the rats learn to drive and why it
seems to reduce the spin the next part
the rat comes on shoots another rat from
road rage yeah rats coming out and
boxing on she rises duking it down the
side rats come in with police cars but
they're white rats and then the black
rats like putting his hands up yeah oh
no so I'll give you some more real life
like why do we give a [ __ ] about this
yeah they're saying that driving tests
could be used to probe the effects of
Parkinson's disease on motor skills and
spatial awareness or the effects of
depression on motivation okay they
should leave with that this point I'm
not saying yeah I'm saying they're no
but I saved it oh you saved it I did no
ideas at the end of the article Tomasi
thing
but you know what though you guys should
subscribe really quick you're welcome
thank you they should lead with that cuz
it's like scientists let me like Oh rats
can ejaculate the same way humans do and
we've been jacking out these little tiny
rat penises this whole time
and you're like awesome well how does
that apply oh we can cure Edie in humans
yeah okay that makes sense that still
makes sense at first I thought this
guy's a [ __ ] pervert I saw this one
read the whole thing huh I I was reading
this one hand time manga it's called
bondage fairies and Marie Tommy yeah
they it's a series and they go
throughout they go throughout the forest
and then they help like creatures and
[ __ ] and then there was a mall that had
a boner and he just couldn't like relax
and then yeah she [ __ ] the mole where
are you naked while you watch this no
I'm like reading it it's a good story
oh I get there but you want to get hard
yeah and the night to get hard did I
come and then I finish I finish it's
like a romance novel you're still
reading as you're going and in the book
shaking and I'm jacking off like this
and I have to wait and I come in and I
go back and I flip the pages yeah all
the top all corner parts just have
lotion
jerk it then but then it's so well
constructed because they time to come
right so after you bust a nut you flip
the second page and it's almost like
they know what you just did okay and
then it goes back to story tested on
rats first yeah they probably did I know
what to buy for your birthday and a book
stand so I have a book stand but I think
more of a music stands you need the
audio books then that could turn the
papers for you Oh
with ham [ __ ] no because that I need to
see the visuals yeah so pictures don't
[ __ ] why not a video why did it read
it these nocturnal imagination the
pictures no no about you imagine in
between like between each image comic
book-y [ __ ] Japanese why didn't they
make the jacking off says you're so
[ __ ] complicated get the reading
bucket walking turn pages all I'm saying
is though it was it was awesome because
they [ __ ] mr. mall but what we found
out was mr. mole is just a stupid
pervert right and in mr. mole got into
the fairies underwear drawers drawer and
he's been stealing that and sniffing it
and then the bondage fairies were like
hey mr. mole that's [ __ ] that's where
my underwear way and it was all a dream
he never got to [ __ ] them and then it's
because you're talking about rats
ejaculating cuz then I thought about mr.
Moylan god I think you read my [ __ ]
brain well I'm like why are you telling
us so missus you gave me that face
that's why so mr. Hall is that having
blue balls in real life yes and in there
laughing he was sniffing their underwear
and [ __ ] and then mr. moles wife came
home and she was like oh my god there he
is again and no no no no but the body's
ready had to go away cuz they're like
that guy's a [ __ ] weirdo so even
though this was a fairy tale mr. mold
didn't get any fairy tale oh yeah that's
a good one
very nice yeah where's the bondage fairy
Joe so a bondage theory is a is a
special fairy in the forest and they
wear bondage like clothing and their
little fairies like this very well no
they're in yeah like think of Smurfs but
like like you know little [ __ ] Smurfs
in the forest right ball gags but yeah
yeah literally like the guy ones they're
like they look like by Chris tripperz
and [ __ ] and then there's like girls
that are like hot little like like
fairies that are in bondage and should
they're like in stilettos and and like
vinyl suits and then they fly around the
the for is it in they fight crime forest
crime
you know there might be like a backlog
[ __ ] beetle rapist out there and she's
like hey stop [ __ ] all the other
beetles you [ __ ] and then he's like
but I'm so horny and then she's like
literally and oh be like whoa what's
going on and he goes oh I have this
thing stuck on my balls and she's like I
gotta fix it then and then so they [ __ ]
him and he's like thank you now I'm not
horny anymore so they just fight crime
through sex and I think it's a great
series seems like there's a lot of Part
two supposed to jack off to there you
guys you are sleeping on some good
content manga and [ __ ] hentai porn
mangas have some great stories
they do though they do they do I read
one about octopus those pretty
interesting you think it's better than
uh like human porn visual yeah because
it's literally so like you're not into
manga and anime so if you're into that
stuff
like Pokemon or whatever right that's
for children but they're literally just
good [ __ ] stories but then you just
add sex into it so they're good [ __ ]
start I like it when a woman is being
held in midair by octopus and then
Oliver holes are being taken by this one
maybe like before I was still in high
school is it called Octopussy no but
seriously it's like so like one it might
be like 50 pages right so imagine like
50 pages but like 30 of it is story and
20 of it is nudity and sex so like most
of it is is just good [ __ ] story do
you think it's kind of like the Playboy
magazines were no it's like a romance
novel so like but like sure you had the
story but do you think there's a lot of
guys out there just skip those 30 pages
and go straight for the sex so it's like
you know if that was a case watching
porn does the job I do be willing to go
on Larry King show and explain manga to
him yeah and hand-tight a thousand
percent I wish you just did it you know
what just happened to Larry King and you
you guys are the weird ones now cuz
there's a [ __ ] you in our audience
Danny we're letting you run I asked you
what my theory was so there's a lot of
people in our audience that are already
on this [ __ ] because Japanese culture is
in and they're already into anime and
they're just going right into that edgy
stuff nobody seen you not pioneer we we
gave you that credit I'm just saying
that Power Rangers was in Japan before
came to America yeah and I'm a pioneer
how about this what's a good intro
what's a good intro into that into your
world I don't know or just good jump
straight into bondage just type in
hentai manga
[Music]
[Music]